now you've said previously that the
Conservative Party needs to dramatically
change so what do you want to see in the
budget well I think this is the most
important budget in a decade the
conservative spark party has just spent
the last 10 years sorting out the
economic mess that the last Labour
government left us but we can't just be
defined there's a party that comes in
and cleans up after the last Labour
government what we need to do in this
coming budget is set out what our vision
for the country is then it should be one
around opportunity social mobility and
we need to be talking to a brand new
generation of people in our country who
maybe are 20 or 30 and all they've seen
us do is try and get the economy back in
the shape all they've heard from us is
around how we have had spending
constraints we now need to do is tell
them what we're actually about which is
about giving them more opportunity so
that they can reach their potential and
in doing so helped this country to reach
its own potential and I want to just ask
you about something you said a fringe
event at Conservative Party conference I
think we could have a quick look and at
what you were quoted is saying this is
about the treasurer you said it doesn't
have a framework for valuing investment
in people whether it's health or
education or early intervention that's
not seen or accounted for as an
investment instead it's always been seen
by the Treasury as a cost what did you
mean what I mean is that as it sounds
like we'll we'll hear more Rhodes
investment tomorrow and of course that's
welcome but in the end what's going to
determine Britain's success whatever
happens on brexit is going to be people
and it's the people who get in those
cars it's the people logging on through
improved broadband and their skills that
will make the difference and what I was
saying was that Treasury does not value
investment in people properly and
because of that I don't think we get the
right decisions out of that Department
and it now needs to fundamentally reform
to make sure that in a knowledge-based
economy which is the 21st century were
in we actually get sensible decisions
taken by Treasury and sensible
investment in people and dare I say you
had a discussion with Francis O'Grady
about Amazon if we can better understand
how we've
you investment in people we can also
understand how we should deal with
companies in terms of how they invest
and deal with people and that could then
not just feed through and to spend it
could feed through into the tax system
that's the kind of reform I'm talking
about and it goes alongside saying what
do we need to do both in terms of
investment but more fundamentally how do
we need to reform government to make
sure that we unlock the potential of
people around our country this is a long
term structural problem that Britain has
never tackled and we now absolutely have
to get to grips that I also pushed the
transferor own Universal Credit I know
it's something that a lot of
conservative MPs are worried about
people effectively some people losing
out as a result of those reforms are you
worried about it and could you support
in in vote the current universal credit
policy unless there's reform I am
worried about it and I'm one of those
MPs saying to the Chancellor that I
think it does need to be changed to make
sure that it can work on the ground and
this is a good example of the Treasury
reform that we need would you would you
vote for universal credit if it isn't
changed well I think it's gonna be hard
for many of us who are concerned about
how this will play out in our local
communities to support it without the
changes that it needs to be successful
and as about say this is a good example
of the Treasury reform I'm talking about
five years ago decisions were taken in
terms of resourcing for universal credit
that we are now seeing playing out and
as a result it's very likely that the
chancel will have to put additional
money in now that isn't a sensible
approach we need a Treasury that can get
things right first time whether it's
universal credit whether it's schools
funding whether it's NHS funding that
has a clear strategy that goes alongside
that so you've just heard from John
MacDonald inand it's the usual labor
message more spending no strategy just
more spending we have to get out of this
cycle of spending splurges followed by
spending constraints it's not serving
our country well and we need to work out
how we can make sure we have some proper
long-term strategy for delivering more
opportunity for more young people in our
country helping them get on in their
lives and in helping them be successful
that's how we make sure that Britain is
successful you just mentioned on John
or if the Conservative Party doesn't
change as you clearly wanted to do you
think that Labour might win the next
election well this is this is generally
what happens we come in we take some
difficult decisions as a responsible
party in cleaning up the latest economic
mess left by labour if we can't set out
a compelling vision for a country where
the equality of opportunity Inlet space
is 31 years now since the conserved
party last won a landslide election then
we'll do what we always do we just end
up handing the keys back to labour and
that's the cycle that we have our own
horse to do that do you think a minute I
think we we have to now get beyond
fixing if you like the nation's finances
to talking to a brand new generation of
young people growing up in our country
about what we in government have to
offer them in terms of tackling the
day-to-day issues and lack of
opportunity that they see in their lives
as well simple thing that the Chancellor
could do on Monday tomorrow he could
choose to allow young people paying rent
have that flow through into their credit
school which will make it cheaper for
them to get credit we all rely on make
it cheaper for them and easier for them
to get a mortgage that's a simple
measure that the Treasury could announce
tomorrow that won't cost a penny those
are the kinds of smaller things that can
have a big impact but we need a much
longer-term strategy from Treasury and
from government to now show the public
what we're all about and that should be
opportunity for all an equality of
opportunity and particularly targeting
those communities that have been left
behind in our country is tourism a the
right leader to come up with out
strategy well I don't think it's
necessarily about a change of leader
what I'm saying
I don't want to fit our zone what I'm
saying is the Conservative Party is
nothing if it's not the party of
opportunity Monday is a chance for us to
set out what we really mean by that and
that's what I want to see in the budget